c'est encore à l'image sulfureuse ou le
mma pour mixed martial arts typique arts
martiaux mixtes en france est un mélange
de plusieurs sports de combat arrivé en
france au milieu des années 90 les
règles sont claires
tout est permis ou presque les coups de
genou au visage sont interdits les coups
de coude sont interdits étant quelqu'un
est tombé au sol on n'a pas le droit de
donner des coups de poing et coups de
pied 1996 l'un des premiers tournoi est
organisé à nancy
pourtant les compétitions sont illégales
en france car la loi interdit les
frappes au sol seul à pratiquer en club
est tolérée
face à cette marginalisation les adeptes
milite pour la légalisation des tournois
mais certaines personnes s'y opposent
jugeant ce sport trop violent le sport
c'est l'amitié la rencontre le respect l
écoute les changes
le sport c'est des valeurs positives
c'est pas d'aller faire le malin pour
exister sur des valeurs guerrières à ce
point là en donc je comprends pas je
suis atterré de voir ça pour vivre leur
passion certains combattants sont
obligés de franchir la frontière
française
à l'image d'anthony 10 ou exilés en
suisse pays où les compétitions sont
légales quand on connaît pas la
discipline on peut être un petit peu
choqué au départ mais après il faut
passer ce cap là s'intéresser un petit
peu plus
et puis j'ai à partir du moment où on
fait rater les faits on a compris ce
sport n'a pas de raison de l'interdire
malgré ces revendications le mma n'est
toujours pas reconnu en france
pire en 2015 nouvel obstacle pour la
discipline
le gouvernement s'oppose fermement à une
égalisation des compétitions sur le
papier seulement
car aucune loi n'interdit officiellement
leur tenue
face à ce flou juridique certains
défenseurs de mma n'hésitent pas à
braver les consignes et organise des
tournois à paris super j'attends de voir
ça 2015 un gala de mma est organisée au
cirque d'hiver à paris
1600 personnes assistent au rendez vous
c'est une soirée historique c'est la
première en france soirée et même a
parfaitement réussi le contrat est
rempli
en réaction à ce gala un arrêté pris en
2016 interdisant toute compétition de
mma en france mais en 2018
face à la popularité de ce sport le
gouvernement ouvre la porte à une
possible légalisation des compétitions
sera une reconnaissance pour les
combattants ça leur donnerait pouvoir
combattre chez eux avoir des gros
événements chez eux avaient été des gros
combattants se montrer et bien sûr ils
vont exploser au point de vue
international parce que les français
sont de très bons combattants
en janvier 2020 le mma est
officiellement reconnue par la ministre
des sports roxana maracineanu
[Musique]